herzlich willkommen wenn es eine
denkerin des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
gibt deren thesen direkt zu unserer zeit
sprechen dann ist es hannah arendt ob es
um die banalität des bösen geht das
wesen von totalitären systemen oder aber
den sinn von arbeit keiner hat darüber
tiefer und einprägsamer nachgedacht als
abend vor allem war sie eine denkerin
die das streiten als eigentliches
lebenselixier einer offenen gesellschaft
heraus stellte warum das will ich heute
mit der berliner philosoph in eva von
kritiker besprechen herzlich willkommen
vielen dank für die einladung
es ist ja so hannah arendt ist nicht nur
eine der bedeutendsten denkerinnen des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts ist in jüngster
zeit zu einer art ikone man könnte sagen
zu einer art kult gestalt geworden
schulen straßen schnellzüge werden nach
ihr benannt texte aus dem nachlass
schießen auf die bestseller-listen
wie kann man dieses phänomen erklären
welche sehnsüchte werden da bedient
vielleicht soll man solche geheimnisse
gar nicht lüften nicht dass sie sich
verflüchtigen
ich glaube da gibt es eine antwort aus
der ökonomie der knappheit es gibt
einfach ganz wenig überhaupt so
brillante denkfiguren aber erst recht
aber sonst überhaupt keine vielleicht
noch aus als im auto war so
charismatisch und einflussreiche frau
können sie lange suchen insofern
konzentriert sich da ganz viel
aufmerksamkeit und aus der ökonomie der
fülle würde ich sagen das ist einfach
ein unerschöpfliches werk also viele der
thesen der vorschläge der begriff der
beobachtungen sind so abgegolten und
haben noch so viele reiche
anwendungsmöglichkeiten es wird also
auch eine art wird ja immer aktuelle
also alles was ich bis 20 jahrhundert
prophezeit hat an kernthemen kommt also
jetzt umso stärker wieder an der
oberfläche und genau sie sind politische
philosophin sie lehren in berlin an der
humboldt-universität würden sie denn
sagen dass abend auch die verkörperung
ihrer philosophie sie selbst ein
leitbild ein vorbild charakter
[Musik]
also ich glaube sie hat mich tief
geprägt und es war wichtig solche solche
bezugspunkte zu haben ich glaube wenn
man bei vorbildern verbringt man zu viel
zeit mit dem vergleichen und also das
lenkt ab es wäre schwierig und lenkt ab
vom geschäft aber ich glaube es gibt
wenig werke man kann sich ja nicht mal
was so vertiefen dass man sozusagen
immer mitdenken kann was wäre jetzt die
abendshow perspektive da drauf und genau
das würde ich sagen hat mich schon dass
er nicht losgelassen seit ich angefangen
waren zu lesen
wir sprechen jetzt über annähernd als
philosophin als große philosophen des 20
jahrhunderts das ist ja eigentlich eine
ganz ungewöhnliche und fast neue
wahrnehmung zumal hannah arendt als
akademische philosophie gar nicht stark
wahrgenommen oder es gibt wenig kurse es
gibt wenig relativ mäßig und der
literatur ist denn hannah arendt
überhaupt als philosophin richtig
angesprochen aus ihrer sicht ja also ich
glaube das gibt da ja immer den bezug
auf ihre koketterie damit dass sie gar
keine philosophen sei sondern eine
politische theoretikerin wir können
daher noch mal mehr dazu sagen warum ihr
das so wichtig ist aber der selber immer
man kennt sich selbst am schlechtesten
und man wird von außen erkannt und
wahrgenommen natürlich würde ich sagen
dies nicht aus dem kanon aus china wenn
man es tut dann umso schlechter für die
philosophie ja und ich glaube dass sie
deshalb als philosophin so einflussreich
auch ist oder man sagen kann dass es
nicht nur eine pünktliche theoretikerin
weil sie wirklich aus der grundlagen der
begriffliche vorschläge gemacht hat oder
auf der ebene gearbeitet hat deswegen
doch ich würde an der philosophie
zuschreibung festhalten sie sagt man
kennt sich selbst vielleicht am
schlechtesten und man wird von außen mit
gewissen zumutungen belegt das kann man
im fall von arendt auch deswegen sagen
weil sie eine philosophin war eine frau
würden sie sagen dass die teil der
faszination in der tat liegt dass sie
eine frau war ich frage dass auch
deshalb waren selbst zu dem was man
gemeinhin feminismus nennt großem
abstand gehalten
arendt kannte ja den feminismus in dem
reichtum wir inzwischen auf uns gekommen
ist gar nicht und ich glaube dass sie
mit manchen gegenwärtigen strömungen
also sowohl teer oder auch manchen
anderen strömungen der 70er jahre
vielmehr hätte anfangen können als mit
diesem einen kontakt simon der boa die
instanz abgewiesen hat ich glaube sie
hat ja selber gesagt das problem habe
sich für sie nie gestellt also ich dabei
und hat als jemand die sich voll bewusst
war dass eine ausnahme zu sein lange
nicht heißt dass bestimmte probleme
überwunden sind trotzdem für sich selber
ganz viel spielräume wahrgenommen und
daran ist ebenso ein wahnsinnig guter
orientierungspunkt aber ich glaube nicht
dass man sagen kann jahren zeigt es doch
wir brauchen keine feministische theorie
dazu wir brauchen nur diese großen
denker sondern das ist kein zufall warum
gerade also eine einzige figur das dann
geschafft hat auf ganz viele umwege sich
zu etablieren und auch zu ihrer frage
eben mit dem akademischen an der
rezeption im akademischen abend hat sich
ja selber sehr geschickt zum teil auch
rausgehalten immer versucht keine feste
professor zu kriegen wenig
lehrverpflichtungen weiter schreiben zu
können und dadurch hat sie glaube ich
ihre berühmtheit erstmal er außerhalb
der akademie gefunden und dass sie jetzt
so wenig oder nach wie vor nicht sehr
stark systematisch rezipiert wird hat
glaube ich auch was sich so eine art
flucht er aus dieser popularität mit der
wir eingestiegen sind auch hört ja also
je mehr ich weiß nicht wir machen uns
hier ja mit schuldig aber je mehr der
personenkult betrieben wird umso stärker
scheint es dass seine figur also der aus
philosophischer sicht feuer
touristischen halbwelt und nicht der
sekundärliteratur meter kann man sagen
die popularität auch die zugänglichkeit
das team gespürt dass sie hatte hat die
akademisch zunächst erst geschadet und
erst jetzt begreifen wir was da auch für
die systematischen philosophie drehen
wäre eine sache
das wären einige jahre sind eine sache
tritt glaube ich hervor hannah arendt
eine deutsche jüdin sie war damit in
ihrem zeitraum zur flucht zur erfahrung
gerechte losigkeit verdammt sie war auch
ein mensch der wichtige leer und
liebesverhältnisse hatte und sie war
eine philosophie über all diese drei
dinge selber werke geschrieben hat das
heißt viele ihrer systematischen und
philosophischen impulse kommen aus dem
eigenen leben ist das auch ein geheimnis
dass man das eigene leben und die
eigenen probleme zur grundlage des für
die sophie uns nimmt genau ich dabei und
würde immer entsetzt von sich weist das
eigene leben ist also und es hält sich
glaube ich etwas gegeben was einem gar
nicht auf derart verfügbar ist als
eigenes land hat aber und darin
sozusagen phänomenologische geschult
immer gesagt dass man aus der erfahrung
denken muss und ich glaube sie
interessiert dabei gerade nicht die
private erfahrungen die sie für ganz
also das hält sie ja immer verlangen
weil ich dafür eigentlich bei allen
gleich und was sie interessiert sind die
politischen erfahrungen und ist das
verstehen dessen will in welche
situationen menschen geworfen sind und
dann mit welchen kategorien man darauf
reflektieren kann die man dass anleger
die ins freie führen
da will ich gleich mal bleiben in
welcher situation man als mensch
geworfen hat und was daraus folgt das
erste werk von abend kann man sagen
handelt von einer deutschen jüdin rahel
varnhagen aus dem 19 jahrhundert also
seine philosophische biografie und macht
dort eine unterscheidung sehr
interessant sehr tragbar ist die
zwischen einem park avenue und einem
pariser wie sie sagt als jüdin in
deutschland hatte man diese zwei
optionen insbesondere als frau was wird
diese unterscheidung in sich pari pari
genau also sozusagen unter bedingungen
wo echte gleichberechtigung nicht
möglich ist gibt es nach arendt die zwei
alternativen dass man sich entweder
versucht anzupassen und dann sozusagen
aus dem anpassen und der über erfüllung
der kriterien auch nicht rauskommt ist
das paar über die haft als die
assimilation par excellence mit der man
dann womöglich ist sogar ganz gut in die
oberen ränge der gesellschaft schafft
und wie man die eigenen kulturellen
wurzeln abwirft und zitiert ja oder in
denen man mit ihnen hausieren geht auf
eine explodierende weise die 1
dann wiederum interesse verschaffen es
gibt glaube ich beides und das betrifft
dann auch genau diesen ausnahmestatus
den siebt ist am sehr fragwürdig fand
und ist da sehr brüsk und sagt als und
natürlich kann es sein dass leute sich
gezwungen sehen diese anfang an zu
machen aber man verliert da auf eine art
sich selbst und also weil wir eben schon
davon sprachen seinen den zugang zu den
eigenen erfahrungen wenn man nur noch
damit beschäftigt ist irgendwie
passenden zu funktionieren zugleich
authentisch wie ja arendt hat zur
authentizität ja eine ganz andere
meinung hat sich also ich glaube nicht
dass da was inneres wäre was man dann
wahrhaft ausdrücken oder eben verfehlen
kann aber als eine gerade weil man
versucht sich auf eine bestimmte art
selbst zu präsentieren ist man abgelenkt
vom eigentlichen leben und handelt nach
arendt und die alternative des paares
was er denkt was reifen haben so am
allerletzten moment auf dem sterbebett
deutlich geworden ist unter dem guten
einfluss ihrer besten freundin und also
man kann sagen auch ein bisschen der
autorin oder biografen abend selbst das
ist eigentlich die würdige reform der
paria staat es ist sozusagen das
zugeständnis oder auch der mut sich in
dem außenseiterstatus einzurichten und
zu sagen ich versuche jetzt gar nicht
daran zu kommen ich bleib hier in dieser
prekären beobachterposition unter
anderem weil sie mir eine ganz
privilegierte erkenntnis des
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalts von
außen von auch als jemand der sozusagen
auf arten an act oder erfahrungen macht
die sonst nicht gemacht werden können
und ich glaube man kann das jetzt nicht
als globales rezept verkauf also man
brauche überhaupt grundlagen die es
einem ermöglichen
weiter zu existieren aber für sie waren
dann zum beispiel so jemand wie heinrich
heine im grunde aus vorbild von jemanden
der sein gerade in diesem spielerischen
dieser ironie diesen nicht karrierist
ischen eigentlich die also viel besserer
besseren blick auf die deutsche
gesellschaft seiner zeit hatte aber es
ist ja schon zu einer sehr ernst und
auch würde ich sagen aktuelle frage was
es heißt eine identität oder mehrere
identitäten zu haben
gerade heute spricht man davon dass ich
zum beispiel sportler sagen wir mit
albanisch schweizerischen oder deutsch
türkischem hintergrund zu einer von
beiden kulturellen hintergründen
bekennen sollen und dann gibt es eine
dynamik die ja ganz ähnlich ist einmal
werden sie zum paris oder man wirft
ihnen vor sie seien ein paar
und beides wird gegen sie verwendet
genau da war und würde natürlich sagen
also in dieser beschreibung da kommen
schon alle übel des abendlands zusammen
also sowohl die obsession damit eine
identität haben zu wollen
heldt an der vor einem also große
ablenkung vom eigentlichen geschäft und
für eine üble erbschaft der christlichen
und sorge um die seele und um das eigene
seelenheil die einen ablenkt davon auf
die welt zu schauen sich um die welt und
die gemeinsamen angelegenheiten zu
kümmern
aber ist die erfahrung teil einer
gemeinschaft zu sein nicht auch etwas
sicherer
das von dem aus die welt und jahre das
ist zugehörigkeit und nicht identität
nach arendt ich glaube und würde sagen
die dieses selbst verhältnis als festes
beschreiben zu wollen für unmöglich dass
eine mehr in einer gemeinschaft
beizuwohnen und gerade das eben sagt mit
albanisch schweizerischen oder wie auch
immer ein deutschtürke das andere übel
was damit rein spielt ist dann die
vorstellen dass das nationale etwas
identitätsstiftendes gibt also jahren
dachte einer der großen politischen
katastrophen die sich 19 jahrhundert
ereignet haben ist dass der so sie nennt
das die nation den staat erobert hat
also dass wir überhaupt nicht mehr
anders über politische gemeinwesen
denken können als mit einer vorstellung
nationaler homogenität das rührt
sozusagen daher dass ich in der
französischen revolution
volkssouveränität und
nationalstaatlichkeit verquickt haben
war nicht mein schon auf frankreich
trifft das mir diese homogenität nicht
zu erlauben sie auch basken und salaten
und alles mögliche aber dass das das
modell des nationalstaats geworden ist
und alle diese staaten dann besonders
nach dem versailler vertrag nationale
minderheiten hat mit dem sie gar nicht
wussten dass mit den anfangen so susanne
beschreibung nicht eben also in einem
arabischen verständnis von politik und
zusammen handeln würde sich diese frage
nach identität als so einem kriterium
das was man isst welchem nation ein
kollektiv man zugehört gar nicht stellen
oder das wäre jedenfalls ihre vision
eines auswegs die identität waren selbst
für sich gewählt hat war die idee nicht
zugehörigkeit nächstes außenseitertum
sei es in bezug auf das judentum oder
der selbstbeschreibung als jüdin als
frau als kommunistin
dies und das sie lehnte es vollkommen ab
teil einer gruppe zu werden sie
verbindet das glaube ich auch mit dem
ideal eines denkens ohne geländer das
heißt auch dass gemeinschaften das immer
verhindern eigenständig überhaupt denken
zu können
also ich glaube dir vor homogene
gemeinschaften also alleine kann man
nach arendt erst recht nicht denken das
heißt irgendeine form von gemeinsamkeit
kollektivität brauchen sie immer aber
als resonanz als resonanzraum als bühne
als sozusagen gegenüber und ab nach
jahren ist aber je offener sich das
gestaltet die chance desto größer das
man selbst und eine eigene person
entwickelt die sich also nach abend
immer nur im wer einer ist also in der
individualität und nicht mehr in dem was
der vielen sozialen zugehörigkeiten
verwirklicht genau
sie sagten das denken muss man
eigentlich alleine pflege und kultiviert
man kann es nicht allein lernen und
ausüben es gibt eine person ins leben zu
der sie gegangen ist um wie sie selbst
sagte das denken zu lernen das waren 19
jahre 1924 als 18 jahre alt und sie ging
nach marburg und den stillen meister der
philosophie dort selbst lehren zu hören
das war martin heidegger und diese den
sehen jetzt auch glaube ich gleich
eingeblendet und diese beziehung zur
heiliger war für beide von einer enormen
wucht es war ein enorm wichtiges
liebesverhältnis zunächst wie würden sie
den einfluss und auch die beziehung zu
heutiger in bezug auf arendts denkt weg
einschätzen
also das hat natürlich ganz wichtige
grundlagen gelegt ich würde glaube ich
erst mal das mit der wucht etwas ein
klammern ich meine fall gaz seite der
hatte jede menge genau diese art von
affären und hat wortgleiche liebesbriefe
und beschwörungen an die gleichen
anderen frauen geschrieben und ich meine
heidi hat da auch klar weil du die
chance verpasst ein umgekehrtes lernt
verhältnis einzugehen also es hat ja es
hat ja auch sehr ironisch später in
briefen immer geschrieben dass sobald
sie sich nicht mehr umgestellt hat er
das interesse verloren hat das wirft ein
ganz gutes blick darauf wie ich erfahren
und ein erweckungserlebnis
naja ich meine sie ist da ja sehr ist er
mit einem klaren agenda hingekommen und
ich hatte kant gelesen hat gesagt wir
nicht philosophie studieren kann gehe
ich an etwas
und dann war es glaube ich einen
glücksfall dass sie in einen kontext kam
wo gerade die philosophie sich erneuert
und wo gerade dieses sozusagen die
phänomenologische bewegung von grund auf
neuen zugang vermittelt hat und ich
glaube da wie in so einem katalysator so
schnell wie möglich diese ganzen neuen
sachen aufzusagen war für arendt
ungemein produktiv und als als
intellektuelle leidenschaft glaube ich
war das war das ein großer glücksfall
für sie und genau wenn man glaubt das
ist sowas gibt dann ja dann hat er das
eben noch so eine erotische neben seite
oder eine intellektuell ist ja sowieso
auch erotisch eine sexuelle neben seite
genau die dann ja sie auch weise genug
war schnell zu verlassen um mit dem
intellektuellen etwas anfangen zu können
und nicht als heiler das beliebte zu
versammeln und sie wittern nach
heidelberg zu einem guten freund damals
wie heute dazu karl jaspers und schreibt
worüber über die idee der liebe und was
die liebe eigentlich bedeutet auch da
die figur eine persönliche erfahrung die
dann sofort theoretisch philosophisch
eingeholt werden muss genau und das
raumbuch was danach kam ist ja auch über
vorjahr überall van hagen ist ja auch
eine art dann auch die sozusagen die
selbstkritik der romantischen innenstadt
also das was ich eben sozusagen aus dem
berg der reifen arendt von man soll sich
nicht mit sich selbst beschäftigen
sondern die welt steht im zentrum das
hat sie sozusagen ja auch in mehreren
erkenntnis schritten sich so erst
erschlossen und auch unter dem einfluss
ganz dramatische politische erfahrung
und dann der bei also nächsten viel
interessanteren liebe zu heinrich böcher
abliefern
jetzt weitermachen war und den sie
lebenslang zusammen war eine wichtige
komponente in ihrem dasein ist glaube
ich der wert der freundschaft und der
liebe als gemeint wobei diese
freundschaft und das ist ja auch unser
thema streiten dass unser thema noch
immer ein widerspruch ein widerhaken ein
herausfordern war das heißt freundschaft
war für arendt gar nicht zusammen sein
einig werden sondern ein ständiges
herausfordern
ja genau also ich glaube die die
aristotelische definition dass man in
dem freund 1 wird wäre für waren ganz da
wäre es der spaß vorbei sondern es muss
in der freundschaft einen gegenüber
gefunden werden
wenn man nie aufhören kann funken zu
schlagen und das ist ja dann letztlich
auch das was arendt als bild für das
eigene selbst verhältnis vorschlägt das
ist man nur sagen eben wieder streit mit
sich selbst wie mit einem freund im
denken weiter kommt und nicht im denken
bestätigt wird dass dafür bräuchte man
ja auch niemand sonst es interessante
idee dass man mit sich selbst so
befreundet ist sie mit jemand anderem
zielt darauf ab dass man sich selbst die
ganze zeit herausforderung weil ich ja
also ich glaube ich weiß gar nicht ob
widerspruch einspruch ist vielleicht
besser also man hat ja diese vorstellung
vom denken als etwas man man man stellt
sich etwas vormann visualisiert sich was
vom inneren auge man denkt darüber nach
und lässt dann gibt es im gleichen zuge
immer wieder die auflösungs bewegung
also alles was man im denken tut es dass
man immer wieder merkt oh hier geht es
jetzt nicht weiter oder das spricht
dagegen oder wenn ich von hier
betrachtet sieht es doch anders aus und
ich glaube widerspruch hat schon fast zu
viel
statiker klarheit dafür dann wieder
haben sie zwei klare seiten ich habe das
gefühl dass sozusagen dieses denken und
wieder aufrappeln noch offene enden hat
als ein klarer widerspruch insofern ja
ein ansprechendes denken aber ein
möglichst vielstimmiges denken das
wissen wir alle dass diesen namen
verdient ist riskant es geht auch
manchmal ab weg es hat viel damit zu tun
was man sich vorstellen kann ferner
abend kamen uns hat 32 33 in einem
intellektuellen milieu in berlin die sie
war ein schock der nicht nur mit hitlers
machtübernahme zu tun hat sondern auch
mit dem was ihren intellektuellen
kollegen so alles einfiel
schauen wir uns dazu mal einen ausschuss
im interview mit herrn geißler ein ganz
berühmtes interview mit hannah arendt
was damals der schock für sie eigentlich
war
dieser ganzen sache liegt dass man sich
sozusagen zu jeder sache etwas einfallen
lassen kann
die leute sind doch sehen sie dass
jemand sich gleich schaltete weil er für
frau und kind zu sorgen hat dass hat die
nie einen menschen bitten
das schlimme war doch das sie dann
wirklich daran glaubt für kurze zeit
manche für sehr kurze zeit das heißt zu
hitler viel in was ein und zum teil
ungeheuer interessante dinge ganz
fantastisch interessant und komplizierte
und hoch über dem gewöhnlichen büro
schwebende dinge
das habe ich als drucktests kämpfen das
heißt diese sie gingen ihren eigenen
einfällen in die falle würde ich heute
sagen nicht das ist das was passiert ist
bevor wir auf das inhaltliche eingehen
sehen wir da eine frau die über das
schrecklichste lachen kann
die immer noch humor hat selbst im
angesicht von hitler und den seinen
auch eine ganz ungewöhnliche eigenschaft
ja das hat sie ja auch als sozusagen ihr
reduzieren teil ihres charakters
beschrieben also das schrecklich also
sagte ich meine schrecklichste ist dann
wirklich der massenmord und selbst da
hat sie gesagt will sie sich einem
bestimmten ironischen ton nicht nehmen
lassen ich glaube dieses ablehnen auch
von sentimentalität ist sehr sehr tief
verankert in ihrem denken und dem ganzen
persönlichen hass und interessanterweise
wird ihr das glaube ich öfter auch
sozusagen vor gehalten oder es gibt
empörung darüber warum sie so kalt sein
weil man natürlich von der frau erstmal
er das doppelte mitgefühl erwartet und
da gebracht aber sie sagten natürlich
auch es gab eine gleichschaltung im
denken über das denken die weitgehend
freiwillig war und vor allem ihr
intellektuelle milieu betraf was sie
dann ganz schwer entfremdete und an auch
zu fluchen er letztlich führte nach
paris das heißt eigentlich die skepsis
gegenüber der macht des denkens stand im
vordergrund
ja ich oder auch der als ich weiß gar
nicht ob sieht das als die macht des
denkens sondern eher die bodenlosigkeit
oder die die ihre orientierungslosigkeit
oder so was wie der
unverletzlichkeit des denkens ich glaube
sie im totalitarismus buch führt sie das
dann auch sehr weit aus dass das es
sowas gibt wie so eine art frei
flottierenden denken was von keiner sagt
manchmal keine erfahrung mehr getrübt
ist und dieses dieser freue lehre freude
an der raffinesse die dann letztlich aus
also sozusagen ein paar menü ohne not wo
es ja nicht mal darum ging dass endlich
außenseiter sondern das einfach nur die
normalen bürgerlichen karrieren sich in
ihren positionen halten können ich
glaube das hat sie zutiefst verunsichert
das ist aber auch oder auch einfach
abgestoßen das ist aber ja auch schon
eine philosophie kritik die in der
phänomenologischen schule angelegt ist
also für die biologische uhr sollten sie
sagen seine tradition die von rusal
ausgeht und auch über genaue
beschreibungen von sachverhalt genau und
immer den bezug zum dingen voran stellt
also anstatt sich an alten t
hergebrachten theorien abzuarbeiten und
krise den sachen genau
dennoch muss man ja sagen der schock saß
so tief dass sie auch diesen schock des
totalitarismus wir sagen dieses wort so
leicht eigentlich ist es ein wort das
hannah arendt in den sprachgebrauch ein
erlebt hat sie schrieb dann im exil in
amerika an ihrem großen ersten werk die
ursprünge des totalitarismus und das
kümmert oder auch schwierige daran ist
dass hier die erste war die parallelen
zwischen dem stalinismus und dem hitler
faschismus freilegte und damit auch
etwas start was damals fast ein tabu war
nämlich diese beiden dinge zu
vergleichen
sogar gleich zu setzen ja also das war
in bestimmten kreisen tabu in anderen
kreisen wurde ist leider viel zu gern
rezipiert also gleichsetzen würde ich
sagen tut sie die auch nicht also weil
sie auch zum teil wirklich die
unterschiedlichen entwicklung offen legt
weil sie sagt die reinform der totalen
herrschaft mit den durchorganisierten
konzentrationslagern der fabrikation von
leichen wie sie sagt das gab es so nur
im hitler totalitarismus und dann gab es
sozusagen die darauf aufbauende
totalitarismus debatte in den usa die
sehr stark so im ganzen mac os muss man
diese gleichsetzung als antrieb kommen
erstmals und da wiederum hat sie sich
natürlich ganz stark begrenzt trotzdem
haben wir bestimmte linke das nie
verziehen dass sie überhaupt zum
erkenntnisgewinn die sonnensegel
also das ist interessant man muss schon
auch sagen sie kannte sich mit dem
stalinismus und weniger gut aus als also
als sie einfach weniger quellen das war
auch noch nicht so gut erforscht
aber trotzdem ist also dass darin
irgendwie eine freiheit des denkens
liegt alles aufeinander zu beziehen was
man nur kann das ja ich glaube das
charakterisiert das buch ganz gut worin
liegt denn der kern arendt in diesem
totalitarismus ist es die form einer
gleichschaltung die dann das denken und
das selbst werten und das selbstgespräch
verunmöglicht der kern und das berührt
sich mit dem wir sie eben gesagt haben
ist die abschaffung von spontanität nach
abend also das überflüssig machen von
menschen und menschlichem handeln nach
abend ist sozusagen das wesen des
menschen dass wir neu beginnen können
dass wir zusammen handeln können dass es
da unvorhersehbaren momente gibt und das
hängt insofern stimmt die kategorie de
das gleichheits das gleich mal das hängt
zusammen mit individualität und sie
denkt dass sowieso ist in der modernen
massengesellschaft bedenkliche tendenzen
gibt individualität einzuebnen dass sie
auch näher als es ihr selber lieb ist an
manchen gedanken der frankfurter schule
aber wirklich als perfektionierte
perfide methode zur auslöschung jeder
menschlichen persönlichkeit und
individualität beschreibt sie eben
totale herrschaft und dann insbesondere
die konzentrationslager und ihr ganzes
verständnis von politik speist sich dann
daraus oder das was sie später im
positiven dann konzipiert hat als
politik als handeln das auf freier zählt
das ist eigentlich da schon angelegt als
das was der totalitarismus verunmöglicht
und das geht auch zurück auf das was wir
ihm gesagt hatten mit einer vorstellung
von homogenität also eine reine homogene
wirkliche dieses wahnvorstellung alle
alle sollen sein wie ich die kriegen sie
nur wenn sie menschliches handeln als er
unmöglich machen und zerstören sonst
gibt's sofort in die tiefe reißt die
methoden dies zu tun sind teilweise
propaganda methoden sie haben mit
massenmedien zu tun
sie haben auch nachahmer die auch ein
buch geschrieben hat über wahrheit und
lüge in der politik damit zu tun dass
eine gewisse wesentliche differenz
eingeebnet wird die zwischen meinung und
wahrheit und fakt und fiktion wenn ihr
es richtig sehe das klingt ja auch
ungewöhnliche aktuelle globale
herrschende haben die genau auf diese
einebnung abzielen ja das stimmt also
genau 44 dieser phänomene und es ist ja
auch kein zufall dass ich habe mit
anderen kann man auch gut die die ford
elemente und ursprünge wenn man so will
trumps die eben auch schon in der
watergate-affäre und in dem eckhaus
unterliegen nachvollziehen also ich mich
auch jetzt eine kontinuität in der
geschichte jedenfalls momente in denen
sich schon was abzeichnet was dann jetzt
plötzlich überall so überhand genommen
hat zu diesen differenzen ist es glaube
ich aus deren perspektive oder was ihr
nachdenken darüber so interessant macht
und nicht aufgehen lässt in dem gegen
sehr entweder alles fake news oder sein
smart oder ist das eher denkt die
wahrheit ist zwar eine wichtige
kategorie das ist aber nicht die lösung
also sie denken nicht dass wir durch
fact checking natürlich also wenn die
bei seien fakten nicht stimmt dann hat
man gar nicht das was die den
gemeinsamen bezugspunkt nennt dann
funktioniert gar nichts aber basis dass
das aber das ist höchstens die basis und
die meinungen an sich sind kein problem
solange sie in einen wahrheit suchenden
und da sind wir dann ist beim streiten
austausch geraten so lange sie sich
berühren so lange sie zusammengekommen
in der richtigen form und es gibt
sozusagen nicht einen transzendieren der
meinungen an überschreiten diese marina
und es gilt man kann nicht jenseits
derer kommen da ist dann irgendwie
wahrheit und dann endlich streit man
sich nicht mehr nur das alles gute dann
kann man entscheiden was man tut sondern
man muss mit diesen meinungen auf eine
demokratische freiheitliche art handeln
und das denkt jahren haben wir
weitgehend verlernt aber es ist doch
interessant weil wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe hören sie fast hätte er fast
eine kritik raus an dem derzeitigen impf
und gegenmittel gegen jump nämlich
fakten fakten fakten
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe ist eine
reine fakten bei sich um nach abend auch
eine form die demokratie sterben zu gern
der ja das würde sie sagen setzt licht
also technokratischer herrschaft nennen
oder das ist dann gar kein handeln das
auf offenheit und spontanität zählt mehr
sondern eher verwaltung und das wäre
nach abend also der tyrannei mehr als
der freiheit ja sie nennen die tyrannei
und sie haben ein gewisses ideal schon
davon aufgezeichnet wie man miteinander
streiten soll wenn man arendt liest hat
man das gefühl es gibt kein ideal wie
einer gesellschaft funktionieren soll
und das ist eine kleine gesellschaft ist
dass griechenland der polizist
gar nicht so viele menschen die kennen
sich am besten auch noch das heißt die
ganze idee einer massengesellschaft als
einer demokratischen gesellschaft hat
für sie doch etwas problematisches nicht
weil ja ich glaube die
massengesellschaft ist verfahren nicht
nur problematisch weil es so viele sind
und wir uns nicht kennen sondern weil
sie glaubt dass es entwurzelung
phänomene gibt und dass es fanatismus
nationalismen gibt die dazu führen dass
diese masse nicht einfach nur eine
vielzahl von verschiedenen und eine
pluralität ist sondern dass sie in
bestimmte homogenität und in bestimmte
erfahrungs immunisierung führt sodann
das ist das problem der masse nach waren
sie sprechen das natürlich also das ja
auch an also liegt ja total nahe wenn
jemand sich in seinem politikverständnis
ständig auf das alte griechenland
bezieht dass man sagt naja aber ist das
übertrieben so leben wir eben nicht mehr
also mein erstes manöver ist dann immer
zu sagen dass sie das eigentlich in der
reinsten form beschreibt am ende des
revolutionsführers tatsächlich um die
räte bildung in den modernen revolution
geht also die vorstellung und da das
sind zumindest schon mal modernen
gesellschaft räte würde heißen dass
heißt dass sie das ist lässt sich nur
mit modell direkter demokratie wo sich
in bestimmten gruppen also klassische
also gibt's die arbeiter und
soldatenräte aber man kann auch
stadtteil räte am anfang der
französischen revolution waren alle alle
nachbarschaften infektionen und in einer
demokratischen foren organisiert und
einen teil an der jakobinischen
gleichschaltung war die wieder
abzuschaffen also ist dieser moment der
föderation von ganz vielen sich
bildenden demokratisch als ein radfahrer
zusammen bildung von freien menschen die
miteinander verhandeln wie sie ihre
angelegenheiten regeln und das ist ja
dann gar nicht unmöglich delegierte auf
eine höhere ebene zu entsenden die sich
da einigen wie man sozusagen dinge
zusammen bringt welche sachen man
gemeinsam und nicht lokal entscheiden
muss und ich glaube es sozusagen nicht
an die kleine zahl gebunden es ist eine
intensive kommunikation gebunden oder an
ein etwas papieren des bekenntnis zum
elementaren hat auch manchmal diese
momente wo sie sagt naja das ist eine
selbst selektieren der elite die leute
die sich engagieren die sozusagen
spontan verantwort
übernehmen sie versuchen die affären zu
regeln das sind dann eben die
delegierten und dann müssen auch nicht
alle mitmachen ist das natürlich 23
prozent
ich meine letztlich ist es in der
repräsentativen demokratie von nicht
anders aber es gibt eben in einen
wahlstand man könnte sagen der räte
demokratie wird setzt sich sogar
einfacher die dann wieder zugang zu
finden und zu sagen
das repräsentiert mich nicht ich will
anders aber genau da wäre viel zu
überlegen wie das modell übertragbar
wäre aber das ist jedenfalls ihre also
wenn man von der idealvorstellung redet
ihre idealvorstellung von politik sind
solche räte den republiken eine
basisdemokratie als räterepublik das
kann man ja sagen wir suchen auch
derzeit neue freuen uns in dieser weise
zu organisieren es gibt auch neue medien
die uns das anbieten zum beispiel die
digitalen medien
die sogenannten sozialen medien wie
würde denn aachen beispielsweise auf das
reagieren was derzeit auf der twitter
sphäre passiert oder auf facebook ist
dass die agora vor von der abend
vielleicht geträumt hat also um sie ist
ja nicht hier aber ich glaube für arendt
ist wichtig dass das nicht in einer
völligen isolation passiert also sie
können nicht einfach auf knopfdruck die
leute zusammenschmeißen und sagen jetzt
macht man politik sondern sie hat die
vorstellung das ist schon so was gibt
wie sie denn dass das bezugs gewebe der
menschlichen angelegenheiten also
gewisse negative erinnerungen die müssen
nicht alle geteilt sein aber wir müssen
mit teilbar sein also erzählungen auf
die man sich gemeinsam beziehen ja ja
oder um die man gemeinsam streiten kann
aber damit die zumindest irgendwie ein
gemeinsamer bezugspunkt bilden und ich
glaube das was also ist jetzt auch sagen
dass klassische narrativ ist es anfangs
gab es ganze hoffnung in den neuen
medien jetzt sehen wir es gibt dann ist
ins gegenteil
aber dieses volatile daran dass es so
leicht kippt das würde man das flüchtige
und dass das schnelllebige dass es sich
plötzlich sozusagen in dem demokratische
hoffnung plötzlich auf legte man dann
auflöst wenn man sagt jeder hat seine
filter bubble land und jeder redet nur
noch unter seinesgleichen
das könnte man glaube ich also mit arndt
im netz genauso kritisieren wie in der
gesellschaft als vermessungs phänomen
und ich glaube verrat es immer wichtig
dass es irgendwelche formen des zusammen
handeln es gibt und es gibt ja also wenn
man jetzt bei der netzpolitik bleibt es
gibt ja durchaus versucht
so fuhren die früher piratenpartei hatte
er zum beispiel gesagt man kann nicht
einfach abstimmen sondern es gibt lange
diskussionsprozesse und man muss da so
und so oft sich beteiligt haben und dann
wird sie debatte eingefroren und man
kann damit sich alle damit man nicht in
zu großer erregung abstand also ich
meine man könnte einen netzkultur auch
anders organisieren als einfach ein
wilder anonyme foren und dann wäre es
dem arischen austausch von meinungen und
dem handeln wo man einander irgendwie
erscheint näher
ja man ist als intellektueller und
philosoph manchmal aufgefordert obwohl
man nicht arendt ist aber nachdenken was
arendt dazu sagen könnte oder weil hier
mit abend dazu sagen können wenn wir
doch mal beispiel diese aktion effekt
teilweise die idee dass durch ein
weiterleiten oder ein einschreiben in
ein hashtag schon selbst politische
aktion vollzogen wird die auch wirksam
ist würde sagen ja das ist eine der
frauen der selbstorganisation die ich
für richtig halte da würde ich sagen wer
das mit politische aktion verwechselt
hat gar nichts verstanden
naja als mit arndt erzogen der
intellektuelle sagt man dann ja auch
einfach was die eigene meinung hat also
ich glaube arendt hatte eine klare
vorstellung ich hab ja vorhin diese
ganze identitäts kritik krieg
kapituliert hatte eine ausnahme wo sie
ganz klar gesagt hat man muss in
gewisser weise identität politik
betreiben nämlich in dem moment wo man
als etwas bestimmtes angegriffen wird
und so sagen wo sie mal sagt michael
linn angegriffen weil da muss ich mich
als juden wären und dann muss man auch
die jüdinnen organisieren um gemeinsam
die stimme zu erheben und politik
funktioniert für sie sowieso immer so
dass kleine gruppen minderheiten die
nicht unbedingt was teilen müssen es ist
ja auch beim itu nicht so dass ich nur
diskriminiert frauen zu reinigen sondern
sozusagen sehr viel sympathisanten auch
dass die gemeinsam etwas auf die agenda
heben indem sie es politisieren und dass
man dinge von denen vorher vielleicht
gar nicht klar war dass sie politisch
relevant sein könnten dass man dass sie
teil dessen sind vorüber wir entscheiden
wenn wir entscheiden wie wir leben
wollen dass man die so seien auf dem
marktplatz aufbringt und man kann sie
jetzt lange drüber unterhalten was da
alles irgendwie verein seit lcd- und
realisiert und zugeschnitten sonstwie
wie auch immer beim itu hätte besser
laufen können aber faktisch ist es
glaube ich ein wunderbares beispiel
dafür dass ist eine politisierung
phänomen
so leute sich zusammenschließen und
bestimmte sachen an die oberfläche
bringen die vorher im verborgenen in dem
nach arendt ja immer etwas düster und
gruseligen privatbereich geblieben sind
und ob sie da jetzt selber mitgegangen
wäre weiß ich nicht keine ahnung wie
lange aber ich meine das was ja doch
durchaus geschehen ist auch innerhalb
dieser mito beispiel dass bewegung das
neue gespräche zustande kam zwischen
männern und frauen zwischen frauen frau
das neue dinge thematisch worden lieber
sagen können und bei allen gibt es jetzt
wenn ich es richtig hier zwei formen von
gespräch von denen ich ganz sicher bin
welches wichtiger ist es gibt das
gespräch zwischen zwei menschen wie wir
es jetzt führen und es gibt es selbst
gespräch das eine art gewissens kultury
rung für sie ist was ist denn für sie
das politisch wichtigere das gespräch
zwischen menschen oder das aktive
selbstgespräch also ich glaube dass
politisch wichtigste ist sowieso das
zusammen behandeln mit mehr als 1 oder 2
aber damit man das gut macht nach
damit man darin richtung hat muss man
schöpfen aus den zwiegesprächen aus den
inneren und dem äußeren und ich glaube
das ist nicht wichtiger sondern das
hängt zu sagen das kennen sie doch also
wenn wir jetzt ein gutes gespräch haben
man geht doch nach hause und hell
unterhält sich umso mehr mit sich selber
also es ist ja nicht so dass ich
sozusagen die zeit die ich mit jemand
anders rede verliere im selbstgespräch
sondern meistens also fließt das ja
ineinander oder befeuert sich
gegenseitig nicht aber insofern würde
arendt dass beides fünf wichtig halten
sie es gibt manche stellen wo sie sagt
das gespräch mit dem anderen ist primär
oder man hat überhaupt erst anregung zur
selbst werde dadurch dass man erst mal
angesprochen wird das kann man jetzt
jenseits von arendt ja auch also subjekt
theoretisch ist es ja so ja so man
erstmal können sind wir da und griff nur
trinken
ja man wird erst durch die
interaktivität wissen überhaupt langsam
jemand der versteht dass man auch
innerhalb von sich selbst mit sich dass
sie sich unterhalten kann genau also das
gibt es den gewissen vorrang des anna im
freiland andererseits wenn ich ein buch
gelesen habe gravitation zum guten über
hannah arendt gibt es da eine these die
mir ganz einleuchten erscheint die heiße
prinzip es gibt nur einen menschen mit
dem du es ein leben lang auskommen muss
das bisschen selbst versuchte ich mit
ihm anzufreunden und versuche dass die
gespräche mit dieser person die du
selbst bist langfristig interessant sind
ja das heißt doch eigentlich dass die
uns dazu erziehen soll dass wir
langfristig selbst am liebsten mit uns
selbst sprechen
ja ich glaube gar nicht am liebsten aber
allein dass wir ich glaube man spricht
auch dann am liebsten mit sich selber
wenn man in der welt sehr viele
anregungen sammelt und sozusagen weiter
lernt also dass selbst was mit dem einem
nie langweilig wird ist kann glaube ich
auch ein umtriebiges selbst seien aber
genau diesen grundgedanken haben damals
sagen sie also ich finde das auch eine
eine kluge und wahre idee und was was
man auch gut manchmal weiter empfehlen
kann wenn jemand einfach was soll ich
denn machen sage ich tatsächlich auch
manchmal na ja mit wem möchtest du dein
leben und dass das ist dieser
grundgedanke ihre moral philosophischen
entwürfe mit dem sie versucht mehr
hergebrachte vorstellung von gewissen zu
korrigieren oder ersetzen also von
gewissen als etwas was du sagen die
empfänglichkeit für den befehl der
höheren instanz ist oder wo sie schon
innen eigentlich uns der struktur
unseres innenlebens oder unserer
moralität so den verdacht äußert dass da
etwas wie autoritarismus oder angelegt
sein könnte habe ich das mal versucht
versteht ihr eigenes gewissen als als
eine instanz im inneren die gleichsam
unabhängig von einem selbst eine kraft
hat die mich von zu dingen reden oder
dingen verhindert den was bei allen so
ist dass das gewissen eine art selbst
dynamisieren das gespräch mit mir selbst
ist genau also das volle gewissen
das eine ist sie hat die vorstellung
gibt ein gewisses hergebracht das
gewissen als die entweder die instanz
die uns empfänglich für die stimme
gottes macht oder als den hort unser
prinzipien denen wir gehorchen und dann
macht sie diese schockierenden befund
dass viele leute sich das wahnsinnig
leicht und schnell austauschen ließ
besonders eichmann sich auch ständig auf
seinem gewissen weiligmann über die sie
ein buch geschrieben hat gekommen
das sagen die mit den deportationen
organisiert seit dem nationalsozialismus
und das bringt sie dann auf den verdacht
dass irgendwas auch richtig grundlegend
nicht stimmen kann mit der vorstellung
der quelle der moralität so wie wir sie
hegen und ihre alternative
also eine dieses zusammenleben mit sich
selbst dieses selbstgespräch ist
gewissermaßen die grundlage also wenn
sie nicht in kontakt mit sich selber
sind dann kann ihnen auch kein prinzip
oder kein gewissen helfen und nicht mal
ein kategorischer imperativ sozusagen
genau dann lebt man einfach an sich
vorbei kamen und können kann man machen
was man will so arens vorstellungen oder
man kann ja noch sozialen druck folgen
aber keiner keiner innere orientierung
mehr und das gewissen stellt sich dann
eher vor fast wie auch wiederum ein
forum in dem man nicht nur vor sich
selber sondern auch vor einem zu seinen
erweiterten tribunal dass man sich im
geiste vergegenwärtigt vorstellt wie es
aussehe
was man im begriff steht zu tun also
ihre idee ist dass das sozusagen das
gewissen darin besteht dass man sich
bevor man weiß wenn man so sagt jetzt
mal nachgedacht vorher also nach abend
ist dieses nachdenken bestünde dann
darin dass man sich vor augen führt wie
das aussehe also auch wieder so ganz
phänomen orientiert diesen trivial sind
wie stünde ich denn dann da vor den
anderen also wie stünde ich denn dann da
vor mir selbst informiert durch die
perspektive der an
denn das was das ich mit dass ich an was
etwas selber missfallen habe wird mir ja
oft erst klar nachdem ich mir überlegt
haben okay aber erst für die person
bedeutet das dass und dass wenn ich mir
das klar macht dann will ich doch nicht
die person die das tun
ganz interessant es gibt ja ein
individuum das zwanzigste jahrhundert
über den hannah über das hannah arendt
ein eigenes buch geschrieben hat es war
ein individuum bei dem die innere stimme
und das gespräch in gewisser weise
gekapert wurde
auch zum verstummen kam dieses
individuum heißt aber weiß man er war
einer der dafür verantwortlich war dass
die logistik der judendeportationen in
den osten möglichst reibungslos lief ihm
wurde der prozess gemacht und innerhalb
dieser prozess beobachtung von abend
kommt sie mit einer formel kommt eine
form in ihr auf sprachlich die ganz
prekär wurde das heißt die banalität des
bösen
eichmann wurde sie für sie zur
verkörperung einer speziellen form des
bösen das davor so noch nicht existiert
hat oder so nicht beobachtet wurde
oder zumindest nicht beschrieben
und worin besteht diese banalität des
bösen also sie nennt das banal weil sie
es für eine art oberflächen phänomen
hält also gerade für das gegenteil also
die vorstellung von tiefgründigen
übeltätern dass sie sich dann immer
frecher den dritten weil bei shakespeare
oder so was die wir haben und mit der
auch unser moralisches vokabular viel
besser umgehen kann ist die von jemandem
der böse absicht hat der böses will das
böse zielt und arend denkt und ob sie
damit jetzt war ich mein recht hat oder
nicht wäre noch mal eine längere debatte
aber ich glaube sie tritt damit einen
typus den es gibt oder macht eine ganz
wichtige beobachtung dass die also hohe
renten taten in keinem verhältnis stehen
zu den intentionen also man kann
unglaublich schlechten üble dinge tun
ohne sich einmal vor augen zu führen was
eigentlich geschieht und dass dann zu
beabsichtigen also natürlich gibt es
auch und sie hat das ganze jahr über die
antwort der autos prozesse anders
geschrieben und gesagt da waren schon
böse absicht und sadismus und so spielt
bei eichmann hat sie das gefühl da gibt
es einfach so eine art geölten
bürokraten der sich nicht einmal vor
augen geführt was er tut er einfach
funktioniert in einer stelle in der rein
gesetzt wurde also als rädchen im
getriebe und jahren denkt eben das
rädchen im getriebe sein dass es eben
gerade keine entschuldigung sondern das
gerade ist das schockierende dass der so
zeigen sich wirklich zum rädchen im
getriebe gemacht hat in dieser also
einfach funktioniert hat in einem
teuflischen system das er hat es hier
nicht so wie er es beschreibt als selbst
erniedrigung empfunden noch nicht als
letzten erhebung sondern als eine form
der pflichterfüllung er eigene
bescheidung gleichsam egal ob da gar
keine selbst erhebung es gibt ja so ein
paar stellen wo sie sich darüber auch
lustig macht dass er sich so wichtig
nimmt wenn er bei irgendwelchen
besprechungen mit hohen herren also
sozusagen selbst erhebung die aber
ausnahmen hier ist doch alles probiert
er sorgen als also sagen da man die
größe der führenden und lässt sich das
führers anzapfen kann so also irgendeine
selbst erhebung darin dann auf jeden
fall aber letztlich gar keinen
hass getriebene drastischer
vernichtungswillen sondern der wille
sein pflicht zu tun und denn der stolz
darauf
also da ist dann vielleicht selbst
verhältnis irgendwie sadistisch aber in
gar nicht auf die opfer gerichtet also
das war für sein land für sein projekt
gar nicht so wichtig und das finde ich
eine gute beobachtung dass wir oft den
da das ausmaß der tat schlecht sehen
wenn wir auf die intention kommt man ich
glaube das stimmt auch für für sehr viel
weniger dramatische fälle also ich wenn
ich glaube ist da eben drauf kam er
etwas was in der methode hatte immer so
furchtbar schief läuft ist das leute
denkt man macht einen riesigen
moralischen vorwurf wenn man sagt das
war zum beispiel sexismus aber letztlich
geht es doch eine soziologische
beschreibung du warst gerade in dieser
äußerung teil des problems optus
wolltest und nicht sagt völlig egal aber
der effekt der taten sehen
man könnte dann sagen du warst
gedankenlos weil du dir nicht
vorgestellt hast jetzt sich für die
andere person in diesem moment anfühlt
und was es für folgen für diese person
das heißt diese ollen ihrer name wie ist
es für dich zu erfahren wie ich handle
das war bei man dann irgendwie zitiert
ausgeschaltet verstummt derweil hat so
beschreibt arendt das jedenfalls und
sagte er hat darin gerne gewisse komik
erfasst festgemacht und ja auch sehr
detailliert nachgespürt inwiefern schon
seine eigene ausdrucksweise also seine
phrasen in dagegen immunisiert haben zu
merken was er tut also zum beispiel hat
er diese rede übernommen also die hat er
nicht aufgebracht aber von den
vernichtung als medizinische angelegt
ich meine wenn sie das so nennen dann
dann sind sie ganz gut dafür geschützt
sich vor augen führen was da eigentlich
passiert also sowas also ich sag dann
immer bei ihr auf wachmann ist es die
ganoven sprach also dieses sprechen in
phrasen die einem verschleiern was man
eigentlich tut es schon ein gutes
anzeichen dafür gehen natürlich kann sie
auch nicht in seinen kopf gucken und
wissen was er sich vorgestellt hat ja
und wie gesagt sie mag viel gehen aber
auf amt auch darin wieder in der
phänomenologischen methode man kann ja
nur von außen sehen wie er sich
erscheint und darin hat sie den befund
bestätigt gesehen
dieser befund war ein skandalöser befund
der hat einen skandal ausgelöst auch im
für arendt als public intellectual
aktuell
sie hat diesen bericht über den prozess
für den new yorker beschrieben wir
schauen uns mal an wie das in der
redaktions büro des new yorker außer aus
dem film hannah arendt von margarethe
von trotta
und da wird der bericht gerade
eingereicht und die redaktion bespricht
das aus einer allerwelts existenz ohne
bedeutung und konsequenz bode adolf
eichmann vom wild in die geschichte
gerät faszinierend entscheidung so
poetisch anzufangen
ein bisschen übertrieben wie ein blatt
im sturm in der zeit wo denn die
marschkolonne des tausendjährigen reichs
gewählt zweimal hintereinander die band
metapher aber hört euch das an
es war eine gedankenlosigkeit etwas das
keineswegs identisch ist mit dummheit
die ihn prädestinierte einer der größten
verbrecher des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
zu werden
er war einfach unfähig zu denken das ist
originell
das hier ist auch recht originell
dafür werden sie unsere köpfe fordern
überall wo juden lebten gab es
anerkannte juden räte und diese ältesten
räte kooperiert nahezu ausnahmslos auf
die eine oder andere weise aus dem einen
oder anderen grund mit den nazis der
ganze wahrheit ist während die juden
wirklich unorganisiert und führungslos
gewesen hätte es zwar chaos und sehr
viel elend gegeben aber die gesamtzahl
der opfer hätte kaum zwischen
viereinhalb und sechs millionen menschen
betragen
im prozess haben juden retter als zeugen
ausgesagt das muster erwähnt werden sie
geht den opfern die schuld das ist nicht
wahr frei sie unterscheidet ganz
eindeutig zwischen der machtlosigkeit
der opfer und den dubiosen
entscheidungen einiger ihrer rechte
eindeutig übertreibt nicht so das ist
ein kleiner abschnitt und umfasst nur
ziehen sollten von 300 das ist eine
kampfansage
du solltest dafür sorgen dass sie sich
an die fakten hält oder wir werden
bodyguard brauchen für sie und für uns
also ich kann nicht erkennen dass sie
von den fakten abweicht aber was die
granate gang hält
es ist ja eine ganz interessante art
typische dynamik zwischen
nestbeschmutzung und origineller
perspektive und diese originelle
perspektive soll gerade in dem nest
selbst einen reflexionsprozess aus egal
was dieses nest ist das ist ja sehr
unbequem ist das was sie will die
spontanität des eigenen denkens anregen
indem sie störe elemente setzt also ich
glaube in dem moment in dem man das als
selbstzweck beschreibt wird schon
verdächtig aber ich glaube das ist was
sie tut und ich glaube sie würde auch
immer sagen die kritik wäre an die
feinde ja nahezu verschwindet also man
muss ja sozusagen in den eigenen
zusammenhängen im eigenen lager sehen
uns nest gesagt man muss da versuchen zu
verstehen was passiert ist und auch da
versuchen anregungen und dazu bringen
dass das dass sie das mal also welchen
skandal dass dann auslöst also ich
glaube darüber da war sie auch ehrlich
also um ahnungslos vorher hatten das
selbst vorgestellt
genau das oder das hat oder vielleicht
hat sie sich vorgestellt und gesagt so
what does riskiert jetzt aber ich glaube
dass also dieser damit steht und fällt
ja sowieso alles kritische denken ja in
dem moment wo man es nicht mehr als
selbstkritik erträgt wird es auch
verdächtig als kritik der anderen
sondern dann ist es ja eher eine selbst
erhebung oder man findet der den
splitter im auge des anderen
sie sagten vorhin etwas worauf ich noch
mal zurückkommen will man kann sagen
dass arendt das denken als ein kampf bin
ich so richtig versteht gegen die
permanente selbst banalisierung sehen
würde
aus mangel an spontanität sich
vorzustellen was denn passieren könnte
was folgen könnte das hat auch was mit
regel folgen und blinde im regelfall
nun gibt es derzeit unserer gesellschaft
eine ganze linie in dem handel neu
erzeugt wird nämlich über algorithmen
über maschinen die regeln folgen und
zwar ohne jede spontanität ist es zu
viel zu sagen dass man sagt mit dieser
algorithmus sierung unseres daseins
bricht eine möglicherweise neue
banalität des bösen in unser leben ein
also mit allen kann man natürlich
erstmal gewisse kontinuität der
technisierung und maschinen machine
sierung sehen wo die gar nicht diesen
kategorischen unterschied zeige mir sehr
nahe legen würden
gerade so wie sie gerade beschrieben
haben und arendt hat ja auch ne also ich
würde auch sagen stellen als überzogene
technik kritik die denkt genau diese
automatisierung ist teil dessen was uns
so ab richtet das die gedankenlosigkeit
viel näher liegt als das ist jetzt
marschieren werden ja oder dass wir
zumindest versuchen eine gewisse
reibungslose nachzuahmen die maschinen
haben jetzt mit der algorithmus ehrung
ist es natürlich noch mal also ein paar
ecken komplizierter denn den neuesten
maschinen learning techniken haben ja
sogar eine gewisse attraktivität also
das schlimme daran ist nicht dass das
ganz klar vorhersehbare regel folgen
abläufe sind wo man dann einfach sagen
kann genau das ist eben kein handeln so
und gehandelt wird anderswo gehandelt
wird er wenn man sie programmiert und
gehandelt wird wenn man sich dann wieder
auf die ergebnisse dieser rechenprozesse
bezieht aber die diese zeigen selbst
lernen algorithmen machen ja also eben
auseinandersetzung mit dem material was
sie gefüttert kriegen gleichen der die
ständig den algorithmus an und den code
und tun das auch arten die dann nicht
mehr nachvollziehbar sind also sie
können wenn sie zb ein beratungs ist
also passiert ist beratungssystem
rechtsfällen oder in der medizin was in
den usa schon viel stärker angewendet
wird als bei uns haben können sie das
nach dem derzeitigen technik stand
wirklich nicht mehr fragen warum es
gesagt hat die person soll den kredit
nicht kriegen und das ist sozusagen was
als ich glaube das kann man gut
skandalisieren ich weiß gar nicht ob man
das mit haaren so gut kann den sie gern
denkt ja dass unser handeln letztlich
immer ein stück weit opak bleibt und
immer darin etwas ohne absehbares und
undurchschaubares ist arend würde
natürlich stören dass das kleine
menschen sind aber ob sie dafür
überhaupt so gute argumente im rahmen
ihrer theorie hat weiß ich gar nicht
aber gab es ja mal nachfragen sie sagten
ja der kern des gewissens ist die
vorstellungskraft mit sich selbst
auszumachen wie man da stünde vor den
anderen und das ist doch ein gedanke den
wir ganz wer mit maschinen verbinden
ich hatte es schwer mir vorstellen dass
ein algorithmus sich vorstellt wie
stünde ich denn da vor der familie da
ich den kredit verweigert habe genau
also wenn man die maschinen wirklich
entscheiden lässt was ja in den
seltensten fällen tatsächlich schon
passiert meist ist das ja mehr so es
gibt irgendwie so beratende funktion
aber wo die entscheidende haben sie also
solche rechte hat man natürlich
überhaupt kein forum mehr also das was
ich eben geschrieben habe ist ja die
vorstufe die nötig wäre es überhaupt
nachvollziehen kann welche was was tue
ich überhaupt so und dann ist der
nächste schritt kann ich mir vorstellen
aber genau das das können maschinen
nicht und das da sind wir jetzt auch
weit davon entfernt dass sie das könnten
deswegen kann sie ja auch nicht wünschen
dass die entwicklung so weitergeht dass
man das auch noch bei bringt also ich
glaube da ist es geraten eher bescheiden
zu sein sie denken das passiert nicht so
schnell es wegen die werden auch so
schnell nicht die menschen ersetzen aber
wir müssen ganz neu darüber nachdenken
wie man eine weitere dimension der
gedankenlosigkeit oder der der
automatisch ablaufenden prozesse begriff
flankiert durch durch gedanken viele
gedanken fülle und selbst denken das ist
ja ein entwicklungsziel für jeden
menschen
sie sagten streit als kontrast als
störung meines eigenen denkens ist nach
art eines aber imaginationen sich andere
szenarien vorstellen zu können ist eine
ist ein weiteres mittel dieses denken
anzuregen was sind denn die
möglichkeiten das zu schulen und
benutzte er diesen herrlichen kantischen
begriff dass sie sagt man schickt seine
einbildungskraft also die im
organisation die besagten auf reisen
also man man muss irgendwie schaffen
diese anderen positionen abzuklappern
und das ist auf eine bestimmte art wird
abend auch dem streit gar nicht so
unverwandt denn sie denkt damit nicht
dass man einfach nur empathisch führen
soll wie die sich fühlen also es kann
gut sein dass ich mir aus der position
eines kontrahenten vorstelle wie das für
den jetzt aussieht was ich mache und es
sieht ganz ganz übel aus und dann denke
ich na gut aber dessen perspektiven fall
drauf wenn ich da stehen da würde sich
mehr darstellen das was weiß ich wir
nicht zuviel migration sondern zu
schlechte soziale infrastruktur haben
das würde ich das könnte man von der
position sind sozusagen doch dass die
person das nicht sieht es gar nicht das
letzte sondern es ist nur der versuch
also wieso eine gymnastik in der eigenen
perspektive tät und natürlich kann man
sich damit auch grandios irren aber
dagegen ist dann kein kraut gewachsen
außer sich weiter zu streiten wenn man
den prozess in offenen betrachtet dann
können natürlich viele der positionen
die man konsultiert auch die können
sozusagen auch selber in aktion treten
und und korrigieren und ein sprechen und
eines dieser reise mitte also man sagt
einbildungskraft auf reisen schicken
dann braucht man ja ein transportvehikel
nach abend sind dann geschichten also
man es reicht nicht nur zu
philosophieren oder auch nicht nur so
dass auch geschickt sondern man braucht
den negativen kontext oder man muss
verstehen welche wie diese position sich
ihre erfahrungen zusammen spielen
aber eine frage hätte ich noch so
formuliert ist interessant wenn man die
ganzen kosten und eingenommen hat wer
weiß man denn welche perspektive die
richtige wäre oder ist ja eigentlich ein
ständiges wandeln um den heißen brei
herum
also man weiß es nicht definitiv an man
weiß es nicht mechanisch ist es aber
auch nicht eine reine beliebigkeit also
an schätze dass er sofort dass man im
ersten moment schon wenn man sich das
vorstellen hat so einen bestimmten pro
und contra promotion art
geschmacksurteil was so ganz spontan ist
intuition ist dadurch ein gutes wort
und man muss da gar nicht treu sein aber
die hilft sozusagen erstmal als als
anfangs und dann guckt man ob die sich
verändert im durchlauf durch diese
anderen position erlaubt man sie
verteidigen kann oder ob man sie
modifiziert und narren ist dann das
urteil am ende immer also es bleibt
daran immer einen sprung der
unvorhersehbar ist oder der teils im
urteilen auch um einzigartige
sachverhalte gibt also sie haben
sozusagen nicht 1000 vergleichsfälle
wurde es das wo sie dann feststellen
können wie sie genau entscheiden sollten
es gibt aber sie nennt das also englisch
sagt sie immer touchpoint management
also als übung der sprungbretter
haltegriffe es gibt bestimmte besonders
paradigmatische beispiel die wir haben
also man stellt sich einfach vor das ist
anstand und man denkt dann irgendwann
person die man kennt und man kann
sozusagen unterschiedlich gewichten
welcher welchem gegenüber man wie
gewicht dann ist sein oder also lassen
nelson mandela das war irgendwie an
stand das war größer als bei integrität
und daran können wir uns festhalten
das ist vielleicht fast meine letzte
frage dieses leben in unsicherheit ohne
geländer ohne letztliche haid das bedarf
einer gewissen stärke nach einer
gewissen intellektuelle fähigkeit wie
kann man den verdacht ausräumen dass
ahrens idee über moral und politik
nachdenken immer auch ein bisschen was
elitäres hat das ist nur für die wenigen
aber eben nicht für die vielen ist ich
glaube die räumt man aus indem man mit
leuten redet die man nie für
intellektuelle halten würde
und dann merkt dass die sich oft viel
vernünftigere gedanken machen als die
berufs denke also ich glaube dass der
dagegen ist also darin selber ist glaube
ich in mancher hinsicht militär aber ich
glaube diese konzeption ist das nicht
also zu denken elitär ist er zu denken
dass nachdenken sei was was die berufs
philosophen gepachtet hätten dass das
der weg ist das ende der demokratie
hannah arendt hat sehr großen einfluss
sie hat sehr wenige schüler oder
schülerin ich will sich jetzt nicht zur
schülerin von hannah arendt erklären
aber wenn sie sich also ist beschreiben
wollten was wäre denn für sie derzeit
die wichtigste spur in dem man folgen
müsste wenn man abend folgt genau also
wenn überhaupt bin ich erzählerin der
schülerin als einzige schülerin also die
einzige person die bei ihr promovierte
hat weil es so bisher will die dann auch
die biografie geschrieben habe und der
wiederum habe ich viel lernen gelernt
die wichtigsten also ich glaube im
moment sollte man einfach wieder
elemente und ursprünge totaler
herrschaft von der ersten bis zur
letzten seite lesen und ich glaube
sowohl die analysen von ressentiments
dem antisemitismus kapitel stattfinden
als auch die ganze diskussion des
problems der staatenlosigkeit und wie
sozusagen unsere frische international
stark gerade das problem der migration
als problem automatisch die ganze zeit
produzieren
da kann man einfach gar nicht genug
drüber nachdenken und das muss man und
ich glaube also interessant oder wenn
ich jetzt sagen worüber soll man
arbeiten ich glaube dass imperialismus
kapitel ist wahnsinnig wichtig in ihrem
versuch die entstehung des modernen
rassistisch
denkst du verstehen da macht sie aber
viel falsch und es wäre gut so zu sagen
da anzuknüpfen und das besser zu machen
das ja ein sehr altes schlussworte sie
auch dazu packen wo sie falsch lag
widerspruch zu erzeugen um zu denken
wir haben das heute versucht und ich
danke ihnen sehr von rettig seine freude
nächste woche fragen wir was die
digitalisierung aus uns menschen macht
barbara bleisch sitzt am philosophischen
stammtisch zusammen mit katja gentinetta
harald welzer und richard david precht
das sollten sie nicht verpassen
und jetzt gleich zeigt die sternstunde
musik einen film über das tonhalle
orchester das dieses jahr sein
150-jähriges bestehen feiert und zwar im
exil bleiben sie also dran und genießen
sie den sonntag wieder schauen
[Musik]